a German Shepherd is traveling the world
to raise a hundred thousand dollars to
make it a better place for all women and
she's doing it all from the back of a
motorcycle Jamie yukas introduces us to
moxie and the cause driving her owner to
keep this adventure going
for more than 300 travel days Moxie and
her owner Jess Stone load up their bike
get their goggles on and start cruising
the open road
75 pound Moxie isn't in a sidecar or
trailer and that often catches the eye
of other drivers what is the reaction to
moxie on the back of the bike people are
almost going to get into an accident
when they see her
we caught up with The Thrill Seekers in
Los Angeles this week as they Trek
across the country
then it's off to South America Africa
Europe and Asia this is more than just
an adventure how did you decide to do
this I wanted a bigger Rim pack so I was
thinking well let's ride around the
world together and I wanted to do it for
a good cause so I had my eye on the
non-profit grow up for a long time and
they do leadership and development
training for girls in 130 countries the
United Nations founded girl up in 2010
dedicated to encouraging and training
young women to be leaders it really
spoke to me and I always think about the
fact that if I had that when I was
growing up I feel like I'd be a lot
further along in my life first time on a
motorcycle the pair's Journey started
last March but Stone learned how to ride
11 years ago in Africa with her husband
Greg as her teacher it was very anxiety
provoking I'm the only female riding and
I have that feeling like people are
watching and thinking oh why is she
riding she doesn't know how to ride but
soon after
she was hooked and the couple did their
first eight month long motorcycle ride
together making their way across North
and South America until finding a new
home in Guatemala here we have our new
puppy that's where they first met Moxie
good girl wanting to get back on the
road with their new best friend they
developed the canine Moto cockpit the
three now go roughly around the world I
just like being able to share it with my
whole pack and we get to go together but
you're the leader I'm the leader you're
the leader of this pack yeah 100 I do
not like being in the back I want to be
the one who goes through the obstacle
first
obstacles like a herd of bison and a
bike Crasher too and while it takes guts
to glide through to far-flung places we
made it to the Arctic Ocean or Malibu's
famous Canyon roads Stone says she gets
her fearlessness from her furry sidekick
if it was just me I would just have my
helmet on and wouldn't want to really do
with anyone somebody else but by having
her she really puts us into the
spotlight I just feel like they always
say man's best friend but she's really
she's really a woman's best friend at
this point in time she is I named her
Moxie because I felt like I needed some
Moxie in my life she's not scared of
anything and it's something that I
needed in my life because it was
something that I struggled with as well
so she inspires you 100 and now can
Inspire others hopefully yes as the
saying goes in life it's not where you
go but who you travel with I'd say for
these three it's also about who gets to
benefit from the journey
for CBS Saturday morning Jamie yukas Los
Angeles
oh I want to know how they came up with
a contraption that she can sit on I just
is so crazy Barkley would never stay put
I love that that's amazing it's so with
a guy with a pink goggle with the
goggles all of it I don't know she says
that she's the one in charge but if she
can't live without Moxie maybe Moxie's
the one in charge in a way I don't know
I'll say this we were talking earlier
before the show about what animals bring
what an amazing thing that Moxie has
brought to their lives absolutely